this week with our lovely gasps the
Debbie machine yeah
the living legend herself my mother in
the better amore in the flesh
welcome to the dank stream back ok I
missed you a lot first time that she's
been in this room since we've created it
it's so cool in here we're not in this
room
where are we you tell us where we are
like France yeah we're going to pair
were in France we're not in this room as
you can see behind us we were in friend
this week's episode is brought to you by
headspace guys get on your way to a more
stress-free life style with headspace
you can go to headspace calm slash Jenna
Julianne download the free app try to
take ten challenge it's ten days of
guided meditation for free right from
your smartphone so check that out links
are also in the description Thank You
headspace thank you guys space for thank
you and believing in us thanks for
believing in us we believe in you and
they're cool people they are cool teams
which is interesting see we wanted to
talk a little bit about that why you
know that they're cool people because
you've said on your end and on our end
but on your end people have asked you
how does the podcast work how do you do
the podcast so for those who don't know
debbie is part of the podcast family
like she legit helps to keep running on
a day-to-day basis she works for the
podcast she's the one making sure all
the sponsors are in order and we're
happy and you're happy but for someone
who says maybe how does a podcast get
started what are all the moving pieces
that you would at least take part in in
this one what are they I mean there's
there's the actual podcast itself right
and then there's broadcasting it to
wherever you're going to go YouTube
SoundCloud
a lot of podcasts go a lot of different
places iTunes stitcher right yes there
yeah we'll play some games later I just
wanted to address this because I feel
like it's kind of interesting for those
people who are curious Debbie Does so
what what is it what is kind of yeah I
think the thing that people are asking
about is how you monetized it how do I
make money out of it and so the thing
that Julien and Jenna do that's
different than other podcasts is they
have a youtube following and so a lot of
podcasters are just radio people yeah
and so they make this podcast a sort of
on-demand radio if you're kind of
old-fashioned like me so the good thing
about what you guys do is you do this
YouTube video which if somebody's
watching then they can see your faces
and seeing you know the stuff that
happens which is fun and then the audio
part is fine too I actually listen to
the podcast
what I'm not in it which are the best
ones obviously because I'm in them but I
there I listen to those when I walk the
dog so that's just listen to the audio
podcast but so how do you monetize it so
you you know you have the pre-production
of the the production of it then you
have the post-production which means
getting it you know wrapped up and all
the links and everything and sending it
out so then how do you monetize it well
in our case it was easy to sell these
guys because they both already had
YouTube followings but when we went out
that we basically said okay look you
know they've done a bunch of podcast so
I think by the time we started selling
sponsorships you guys already had done
maybe fifteen or twenty oh yeah that you
were willing to put the work in every
single week and I think this is one
thing that people don't understand it's
a podcast it's great but you need to
always think you need to do regularly
yeah you can't just do it once a month
or something and go well you know how
come I'm not gonna make any money that's
one thing then the second thing is you
know to demonstrate that you're willing
to you know do a little of the social
part of it yes tell people set up a
Twitter account anything like that so
then we went to the sponsors they're
like oh you know you're already getting
this many views you already have this
many people that are following you
you've already demonstrated that you can
you know interview gas you can do all
these things and so then it was just a
matter of going to look at this just for
instance there's a place called mid-roll
mi d ro ll and they are the ones you can
sign up for them anybody can sign up you
can count and then you can see if
they'll get sponsors for your show
instead
lots of advertisers there and they
connect to shows that have different
kinds of demographics so that's you know
just a hint in case somebody wants to
get started and they want to see how you
might go that's that's it those are I
mean there are amazing tools just like
that for those of you who are doing the
work who are like every week and week
out doing a podcast when you're looking
for things like that that's a great
source like mid-roll is awesome I feel
like you could talk for a long time
about all the stuff you do so we won't
like take up the whole podcast of that
it's interesting it is very interesting
because I've found at least with a lot
of YouTube like anything that I'm
thinking in terms of my whatever I'm
thinking you've super inside baseball
and people are not interested in it like
it's just no thinking you don't care but
with the podcast especially after when
we talked about the fine brothers and
some of that stuff networks there are
genuinely a lot of other youtubers or
other people on the internet that want
to know about how things work so I think
it's interesting to have you talk about
it and have us talk about it because
there are probably a lot more people
than you think that are looking right
now to just get a little bit of advice
or how it started I mean we can speak
from our end how we started the podcast
and then we can talk about how it
happens as a whole at this point when we
started it was just something to do
Julian comes from a background where he
used to interviewed a lot of people he's
really good at it really good and I was
like this was my thing to do and I was
like I'm more than happy to do the
podcasts as long as I don't have to take
on all of the pre and post production
sort of things by myself I don't want to
have to set up the mics I don't have to
do the technical stuff if you take care
of the technical stuff and you upload it
I'm more than happy to help you come up
with ideas and sit there and talk about
it but we also never had any plan to
have anything sponsored or like we would
that was the joke yeah no rules the hell
rose and we're not sponsored and um
it was because we just genuinely wanted
to do it and have another outlet to talk
and do things no it's not in video
format it was more of like a
conversational format and after a little
while you Julian where me
managing everything yourself right yeah
yeah can you tell us about that yeah so
yeah we got to a point where well Debbie
was Debbie like pointed us to getting
into sponsors before I like I had that
workload so once Debbie was getting
sponsors in line for us right right she
works for my company yeah already as it
is so yes she's already in the yeah the
workers Wow
ding ding ding no so yeah we kind of
like borrowed Debbie for the podcast
because at the time the podcast wasn't
its own entity
now it's kind of forming into that but
yeah so basically Debbie had the
sponsors and what I had to do was I had
to email sponsors time stamps when we go
and go into the sponsorships in the
podcast so they know I had to link them
stuff I had to go like email the
sponsors that would come in because
Debbie wasn't full-time with this at the
time like you were just kind of helping
us get started so it was between me and
you kind of just doing everything
whether it's communicating with sponsors
getting new sponsors with the sponsors
we have purchase orders paperwork stuff
like that business things that we just
kind of have to spend time doing and
then it got to the point where I
couldn't really handle all that because
we were growing thankfully and it was
awesome but I just I didn't really have
the time or resources necessary to do
all that so we kind of made you like a
podcast like like focused podcast you
know perfect a time person for the time
and I feel like that's kind of turned
into the base of the well-oiled machine
that we have right now you know what I
mean and so like the moment and you know
the moment something doesn't go through
Debbie that's when there are problems so
everything basically goes through you at
this point which keeps everything
running really nicely so we found a
happy medium but it wasn't easy so we
went through a weird child an era where
I was taking on the workload we tried to
get other help and it didn't work and so
I think the thing is you know all any
entrepreneurial adventure has that or
venture I should say they have most of
them are event adventures as well you'll
have that sort of growing pain kind of
thing and you just have to work through
it yeah the other thing is so there's
only so much of this kit that can be
outsourced because you can't this is in
your house so you can't do the
pre-production you can't somebody else
can't do the production of it is in your
house you can't do that but we did find
somebody who could take the
post-production yes this is the only
thing that I have personally ever
outsourced well I do all my own videos
like maybe we'll sit there and do it
together sometimes but like I've never
had someone else edit something for me
really you've never had yeah or like
someone that does work for you
so I was like that's you know that's
great that you don't have to sit there
and do it Julianne but I was a little
nervous so it's like I don't know what
the [ __ ] is gonna look like yeah so I
mean as the podcast got higher quality
like when we got this camera we started
using real XLR mics and we you know the
the file of the podcaster was like eight
gigs my little laptop would take four
hours to render export put all the
graphics in and get it up on YouTube
four hours that's four hours a week I
was spending on the post-production and
so we finally was like all together we
decided let's try to outsource let's go
to a company that is a professional with
this they can bust this thing out in ten
minutes because they have the resources
the power for but that's also because we
had a small budget where we could say a
hundred percent that's the only it was
only possible because of the sponsors
that run by Debbie and and maintained by
them you like these relationships with
sponsors are not easier also like that's
something you have to put time into
which Debbie has so yeah we went to a
company who now every single time we
leave this room I take the SD card and
literally just Dropbox the raw file and
I'm done which has given me the best
peace of mind I could have had and you
know with with some learning curves
we've kind of gotten to a good place
to where they know our style they know
to ask questions when things are
different and things like that so all
the graphics you see the green screen
the color grading the the mixing of the
audio which sounds better than when we
used to sounds a lot better than yes
that's
help now we have help doing that but
yeah no I agree completely because there
are a lot of youtubers who just toss
things off to the editor whether it's a
vlog or whatever and I never ever
thought I could ever do that so that
even though this isn't like they weren't
cutting together the podcast because
it's one take it's still nerve-wracking
because it's our baby so I would say
that the process now at this point
within our podcast is Julia and I come
up with ideas
my mom has already sort of scheduled in
sponsorships against the the numbers of
listens and views or whatever and you
know we lose sponsors or get sponsors or
whatever it is some people love us and
are happy to be here and other people
want other things that you just you your
relationship changes and grows people
that want to sponsor you yeah which is
totally fine and wonderful and we
appreciate anybody that's even bigger to
take a chance on us and then Julian and
my mom are in talks with each other
about what the sponsorship is that week
and then Julie and I come in here and we
shoot it and then send it off yeah yeah
that's it but but for anyone that's
looking to start something it really is
sort of that easy because we didn't have
equipment we started with two euros
Beamer USB mics GarageBand yeah free on
that on the Mac yeah garage being
recorded our first 20 podcasts on
GarageBand right and we were doing it
with a video camera that could not
recording Vixia right when that have to
pop out this way right little baby or we
got that we were doing we the come in
segments cuz yes we had to cut into
segments record and then when we switch
to the little camcorder both of us
wouldn't be in focus so we got lucky
that we
you guys remember that the og-pog got7
remembers that because I was in this
house yeah yeah but like it really is
that easy though if you want to start
something to just be able to do it you
know don't you don't need to because
there are and I want you to make me talk
about it a little bit because I don't
even really fully understand that there
are podcasts like networks and things
like that that you can sign with where
they take care of all of this for you
and you write in fees yeah yeah and
those things exists but like if you're
just a kid in your basement and you want
to make a podcast like being realistic
about how to grow that following that's
the same as anything else the hardest
part is gaining an audience and getting
people to give a [ __ ] about what you
have to say is anything with YouTube
same thing with anything but it really
is as easy like when I started YouTube
just opening up a laptop and you know
hmm
there we go yes you go up a similar
experience for us with the podcasts and
the only reason that we allowed having
sponsors in it because our other content
is never or hardly ever sponsored is
because the format itself of a podcast
already lends itself to being sponsored
and it's a space that already has it
like it's not invasive yeah for someone
listening to a podcast to hear a
sponsorship because it's a format that
was created but then we've addressed
that right point of time on the podcast
but yeah we that's how we grew our
podcasts and started and that's where we
are at now but can you tell us about
podcast networks I don't know that much
but what I do know that there are a
number of places out there and that they
very you know sort of anything what you
want so let's just say you want to make
it in your house then you want to do
something like post-production and you
can send them out to somebody this was
that kind but there is there are places
where you can go and you'll sit in their
studio and make your podcast you will
basically do the whole thing I've been
on podcast like that so yeah and Shane's
at the time was like that the guy would
go and you're in a beautiful animal
he said it's amazing yeah but it's
really really cool to be in somebody's
there's a guy there maybe not job he's
not he's helping that economy and that
sounds nice but we are also kind of
fortunate enough to have everything at
home which we don't have to leave which
his idea was well I was on rhettandlink
Scott yes a long time ago and it was
just an I think where they work out of
like their building and there was no
person doing anything so I imagine maybe
they are doing must have it down right
now
similarly independent I don't know that
I don't know what their situation is but
grace also too when I did her podcast
that was she had Jack Ferry they're
pretty certain a machine and it wasn't
very good
it's nice when you go on someone else's
podcast to see like their set up yeah
yeah you're like oh this is way
different like a green just had that
little sound thing you know you just
hold a little mic yeah that was it
seemed very young lion compared to yeah
but I mean I think the thing that the
thing I just want to say is what these
two guys eats it mate doesn't look like
hard work maybe to you but this idea of
producing content on a regular basis you
know almost six years seven years every
single week Jenna never misses a week of
creating content and the same thing with
the podcast they haven't missed a week
while that did that one just with just
one recently but right before that you
made it into vacation yeah yeah you made
almost a hundred podcast in a row yeah
you know without taking a break so it's
more that's the thing I'd want to say
people because I come from marketing so
you want to say well how does that you
know huh kabuki cool well did you do 100
of them in a row yeah I mean if you did
eventually you'll find some other for
yourself so we appreciate that I mean it
is it is something that it's a it's a
learning experience and you get into it
for one reason which I still believe
truly that we have that reason behind
why we come in here every week and we
want - we want to have a platform and
you can sit here conversations with you
guys with each other and you know it
doesn't make it easy some weeks you're
really tired and you don't wanna get on
camera but we do it and it's something
that we we care about that's why we do
it we're not trying to get credit or
anything that's were just explaining
ourselves
but I do think it's very cool you know
when I first met you and I started
learning how you two work together I
love that I love that you brought her
into your company and gave her a role
and she was actually providing something
for you it wasn't just like a charity
thing like she was bringing someone huge
to the table and for us to now have that
on the podcast team is even better yeah
well I knew that after I hired her
originally I don't know when I hired you
like 2013 maybe something like that I'm
like well 12 probably 12 12 mm and I was
hearing from the people that I was
working with at the time because this
was before Rome and that kind of thing
they were like you know your mom's kind
of like really on it like your mom's
actually like the best person right
that's good and I was like well damn
okay and you've been invaluable ever
since at least German I do things and my
mom was the one that when we had the the
job offering for a Rome and you sifted
through like all of those like thousands
or hundreds hundreds hundred of a mica
just a limit it could have been three
four hundred right so um we can
eliminate instantaneously right but you
still sifted through we posted a job
offering on monster four but at the time
it was for like it almost an executive
assistant right something like that not
a personal assistant I'm not a personal
assistant but what was it at the time I
know remember but you know what was
weird was so I had to try to interview
people for a job and you know jealous
like I don't need someone to get my dry
cleaning I'm gonna do that myself right
I don't even know what I need but you I
need somebody so I have to interview
people and say well what's the job gonna
be well I don't really know right but
you know and so I took everyone that was
made the final interviews was really
very wonderful know I know all the
ambiguity didn't seem to faze that right
oh they were like it's okay we'll figure
it out yeah yes I'm very very lucky with
Rome you guys so my mom found Rome and
she was like look this is cuz you
interviewed all of them by
I interviewed like five of them by phone
and then met three of them in person and
interviewed them in person and when we
were looking and everybody's like
resumes and stuff you're like look this
is wrong like she literally had her
tumblr page on there yes your tumblr
page like just look at her aesthetic and
I'm like yes Rome Queen right and then
she was so outrageously overqualified
yeah but by the time when I sat down
with her in person it was like eat
whatever you're saying it was a hundred
times worse for me because I was like so
I guess I'm your potential boss you see
I don't know I but I've never real I
don't think I'm ever gonna tell you what
to do so like whatever you think she was
just so nice it was like you know
totally it's cool I totally remember we
took us a while in my arbor and then it
took us a while to get back to her and
she was like I thought I'd missed out on
the job because I hadn't heard from you
in like two weeks I'm like no it really
just took us that long to like get back
to you I think her dude the interview
last yeah there were three and she was
last cuz I thought well my but they's
you know at the end but I know no
offensive I just remember being to her
face I was like you you know you're like
you're to qualified though like are you
good is do you want to do this like it
seems kind of like below you and she was
like yes really totally you know like
arvo she's like kangaroos
I'm from Sydney well I guess I mean I
hope yes one day and people I know
people have asked about it but yeah I
think she we needed to troll but um you
know she uh she has had an opportunity
to learn a lot of things so she may be
overqualified in some ways but in
another way she's had a lot of exposure
to a lot of things and then other kinds
of jobs issue well she definitely got a
crash course like sort of PhD in the
Internet at this point yeah but she
comes from music her family is in
production until she said oh it's got
like a television in an old school
education area she [ __ ] rocks yeah
she really rocks well what do you think
you can't say the effort I'm old I don't
say it
and how do you say like what I think I
said I think Oh what cringe hold on
we're gonna wait here for verdana to put
her head dude because it frustrating
when your headphone comes out like that
I get so frustrated when that happens
and I don't know how to deal with it
other than going on the headspace app I
could be a word I could be out at coffee
I could be somewhere out in the world as
long as I have my smartphone with me or
my iPad my computer I plug it in go to
the headspace app and do 10 minutes of
guided meditation guys it really takes
you out of whatever frustrating emotion
your frustration eating or stress
anxiety everyone has it you you probably
had it this week and I am sorry that
you've had it and I'm even more sorry
that you didn't use headspace especially
if you're a finalist there's something
oh god oh my god between finals get some
head space right now you can do guided
meditation which is what headspace
provides it's not just you sitting there
quietly they tell you how to meditate
they give you a very great crash course
that anyone can really understand and
all you need your headphones to get
started and you guys meditation it as
much as people may not be familiar with
it there's a lot of scientific research
in thousands of years of cultural
meditation going on that all proves that
meditation really does lead to a
stress-free or a less stressed lifestyle
which is important because sometimes you
just don't really think about that you
guys can do 10 days free of guided
meditation with headspace right now by
doing the take 10 program you get a
headspace calm /gen at julian to get
started on that and you download the
free up to the take 10 challenge and get
on your way towards a healthier less
stressed lifestyle with headspace mm-hmm
thank you heads facing please go check
them out make the podcast free for you
guys and it's really good stuff I
actually really enjoy it yeah so I mean
how many is that that we just sent a
podcast talking about vodka
saying and this is our sponsor Thank You
spaces thank you to everyone they listen
to us and supports I absolutely oh my
gosh one of my favorite things is people
who are excited about our sponsors and
reach out on Twitter like just got my me
and he's just got this new headspace I
love that because you're excited to
support and it's not like you're doing
it for us you genuinely like these
sponsors which is because yeah we're not
we're not advertising some shitty
companies here like these are these are
solid companies that really think you
guys are like awesome and the reason we
can find them and have them on our
schedule is because of the Devyn machine
yeah so hopefully we get we gave you
some sort of idea of what you feel like
questions we're more than yes yeah
absolutely I would say my number one
piece of advice in terms of anything
that if you want to start a podcast or
if you want to start anything on the
Internet is never do something because
you want to make money hmm
never ever ever chase money only ever
chase the things that you want to do and
if ever you end up making money I or you
know by the time we paid off a lot of
the equipment because we were investing
back in so that we could have a camera
and it have you know things with it all
the lights that it takes so that light
this room and record for an hour and
stuff like that we put money back into
the podcast to make it what it should be
yes but by the time maybe you're making
money that's just like outrageously a
benefit you know I mean because you can
never expect to make money oh yeah for
sure she's only ever just do what you
want yeah because why else would you do
something yeah solid solid that's an
advice
that's like wisdom right there guys and
that you know these are people that live
that you know it's easy to say it but
you know look I can tell how am I gonna
eat well I get that part where you gotta
find really [ __ ] eat it I think some
people that we work with though don't
don't really take me seriously sometimes
when I'm like no I'm I'm pretty
independent and yet can't be bought and
sold and the only totally man that's
awesome about this offer we push comes
to shove I'm like
I'm over here I'm like no I was serious
people say to me cuz I deal with lots of
guys Hilo and I love what people say to
me look you just convinced Jenna to do
this no I say look I haven't told her
what to do since she was two years old
you might as well just get over there
girl you and me both tellin me you just
tell Jenna this and that you should just
tell Jenna you she should be in my movie
it'll be great I mean come on first of
all that's professional going to her
boyfriends but mom and no I know but
back to the point do things because you
love it and the money will come
yeah or if it doesn't then just keep
doing it no then just start and then
just go off the rails and rob someone
from some banks okay so we got a game
prepared that I thought of earlier that
I think would be really fun have you
ready dude I'm ready for fathers I'm so
nervous
be nervous no you you should be easy to
be nervous so this game I came up with
we're gonna play it with the Debbie
machine okay so the game is called
social media apps or dog names so
basically I have a list here compiled of
both social media app names and things
we call our dogs not their names but
like nicknames we call them so we're
gonna read one at a time and Debbie
machine is gonna have to guess whether
it's a social media app or something we
call the dogs are you ready I burped
good burp so that means you're ready
right cuz you like you're like you can't
even keep all the readiness in its like
a burp at it that's had it had it oh
well that's a two-way street sister I'm
the upside-down face emoji right
let's go okay are you ready yeah first
one is Babu that's an amp nope Babu
sounds kinda like mountains also we're
children all of these are neither one
they're not even nicknames it's not like
we call Kermit Kermie know that we my
name bazaars are weird things we say
yeah yeah we're weird next one is really
bad ooh oh that's a very good fine
I gotta get something ready for this but
yeah turned up musically yeah you guys
were just using them oh I thought I'd
put that past year but you're good you
should be on musically are you a music
are you verifying musically oh no ok ok
you like it though
kick ki k yeah yes oh no ok I know I
can't get all of these passage because
you're you know your apps are all right
ready beep mm I'm gonna say that's a dog
name which dogs I never heard that
before but beep hey beep I would say
peachy no no Marvel so cute
he's the beep beep beep having it's
already beem beem PE amp now be eme obe
I mean I don't know wow that's that uses
an amp okay yes that's not correct Fiber
has been amp fiber fiber Oh viber oh
that has to be oh that's a nickname no
that's enough
Viper's man am I getting that whether I
do it right or wrong
there's so few in her that she is upset
I looks like a victory score because she
has 95 ways to get me a few girl five
ways to get my mom all right lady oh
come on that's bad that's all right
loose loose Klos loose sounds like an
app but it's a very cool dog well like I
don't even know how this is how I
operate it and then I met you and you
operated if I get to so we just operate
like that happens later on language oh
yeah glide just so that it's whatever
she thinks it's now [ __ ] man
yeah
oh all right yeah
don't we jack is uh is that your version
ready beep ah go be pop that's a dog you
know that travel aperitivo yeah beep ah
go is trivago for dogs but he's he's
beep and then beep about a beep ago we
would say about our Bieber and there we
go beep adult beep aah oh god yes so
we're when I use [ __ ] like out of
context I'm [ __ ] noisy you're in the
kitchen with the two of them and there's
this is a whole language going there you
know no yeah yeah you just you orbit I'm
just orbiting now oh my god and this is
the mature version so that's all I got
you
grinder is a an amp what is that
what's where you make sausages
so you're not wrong in a sense no no no
no don't kill it yet
mom please enlighten us how does it
happen
it lets you make sausages well you
pointed that the me I'll be serious
I am you pointed at the meeting with
your camera camera phone and it turns
into sausages no come on what do you
think driver is I'm assuming it's some
sort of dating app
no you're assuming that it is a dating
yes give us more info why is it it what
a Peppa dating Oh must be like mm-hmm
Samuel that is sexual it's from Damon
okay fine I'm glad I added that to the
list make sausages your bar pal oh my
pal bar pal that's a dog named bar
that's why I said more palette bar
picture it's not a bar app no anymore
it's marble I have three more only three
more people listening so it sounds like
an amp she's cracked the code
I'll go is an app Athena I think that's
what you call peachy no that's her
middle name
oh I know zo o sk mmm that's an app okay
she just beat the whole game so
that way you can play the one you didn't
tune into to not be I think how she
calls other people's roles right right
control control runs deep in your blood
and in this room so we're not going to
I'm honored to be sitting in the seat
where Marlon sat so that was the case
because Marlon the hacker because we
come on as that guy got some serious
game or what the true legendary hacker
but the straight face yeah he's got a
poker troll face for sure nothing
nothing he's such a little brother
it's just 21st birthday today today
Monday for you guys it'll have been
Saturday because it's Saturday now but
yes he just turned toward a ladies out
there we can buy you a drink man oh all
you ladies out there when you see him
you buy the hackers yes
you walked him and say hack me daddy and
then by possession but then you say it
hack me daddy I'll buy you a drink but
then you buy me ten drinks sure and then
you hang each other this is my crime
happen like he's gonna be in a bar and
someone's gonna come up to him like just
had a couple drinks and they're gonna be
like I'm gonna have to go tell him that
I love having a conversation with
someone when they do that in the middle
the gums that's like my favorite part of
a car yeah it's so respectful it's very
it makes me feel like I'm being heard
I'm just kidding
all right so we we created a lightning
round
by we I mean I created a lightning round
okay a lightning round yes focus okay so
basically Jenna do you want to like
alternate questions I'm gonna ask him
but or do you want me to ask the
questions and you pressure her to answer
yes okay all right so I'm gonna ask the
questions and Jenna it's gonna be the
pressure
I need headspace bad yeah you do we'll
set you up after the podcast all right
so I have maybe 30 questions here that I
compiled that I'm gonna just fire off
and Debbie has to answer them and fast
and if she's not answering them fast we
have a pressure er here her name is
Jenna mm-hmm we also have a dog crying
outside the door yeah it's Kurt he was
crying around here okay are we ready for
the lightning round
I'm nervous yeah okay here we go
what are you gonna do on Mother's Day
honey you got to pressure her hang
around I don't know I mean what is your
favorite day of the week Tuesday if
you're open to if you were to open a
restaurant what type of food would you
serve and what would it be called the
nickel bite restaurant and what kind of
food you could just get a little bite of
every edge for a nickel
what is your favorite that's my you
can't monetize this podcast as we play
please turn it off if you're looking for
people to appreciate that app here is
not that place you guys are crazy I know
what I'm doing I thought you were the
pressure a professional nudge we could
do that on there I get it that come on
this one's great okay we'll keep that
one I was hating music go ahead sorry I
didn't know I was gonna be like that
what is your favorite time to be on
Twitter Oh any time
why is visiting you Jen Anjali fun why
is it not fun um it's fun because it's
like a lunatic bit you know place women
wise you're not fun it's not fun because
they they have keep very crazy hours
what's your favorite meal Oh little
pasta where do you want to travel the
most oh gosh uh uh China
what airline do you prefer to fly once
that don't crash ideas are Nike
mmm adidas yes good answer what do you
what do you order at Starbucks I think
drink decaf what do you order it's not
like what do you say
hi welcome Starks what would you like to
drink I have a large decaf coffee like
hot or cold
Oh hard sweetener cream I put my own
milk in there you bring your own milk -
stop put my own military take it home
and put it in no I mean I mean I put
favorite TV channel - just leave on the
TV
Oh Turner Classic Movies favorite book
you've read in the last five years
do you wear socks with sandals yeah yeah
yes you do because I live in the
Northeast it's free who do you think
Jacob Sartorius is I have knowing what
do you think he is yes lightning is
lightning
we need a lightning sound Jacob
Sartorius is a youtuber why should you
be verified on twitter twitter is
listening why should you be verified
because some freaking lint
who cried more Jenna or her brother
don't [ __ ] it up
who cried more general her brother
pressure her um I'm gonna have to say
Jenna what about snapchat if it changed
would make you snapchat what we'd have
to change on the app to make you be
allowed active that's nothing they get
taken pictures and all that so there
were no more pictures on side I don't
like taking pictures on my cell you like
long walks on the beach oh yeah what has
been your favorite birthday the one when
we went to Vegas what YouTube channels
do you watch it was your 60th birthday
what chance do you watch I've heard
about this jennamarbles girl okay what
other ones you watch mr. Higa one more
blush saying that deitrick incorrect
it's me
if peach could talk what would her voice
be like right that's true I do watch
Julian religiously um
what if Pete could talk what would her
voice be like like dad yep that's what's
your web browsers homepage what's your
web browser's home page it's like a
mistake because when it comes up I use
Firefox and when it comes up it's got
some kind of like bad you are all that
it's a bad URL that's comes up with the
same but what's your perfect days
weather I'm like 72 Fahrenheit or
Celsius
72 Celsius what is your dream car oh I
know this a 65 a Porsche Blanc
mm-hmm she knows a 911 please what's
your favorite emoji
I kind of like that there's a poodle
yeah that's my favorite
I like that poodle all right congrats
you have meter on there's my prize your
prize is that's not an applause that's
like the opposite that is the opposite
that's things blowing up thank you for
doing the lightning around with us I had
fun with that one and you were good you
were answering them even though I was
asking them fast I know cuz I'm Swift us
with every flower for China is not found
I was flat lining okay
who do you think Jacob Sartorius really
is I know you sent youtuber but I oh I
got an idea Jacob Sartorius musically my
mom reacts didn't it okay so we're just
gonna watch her reaction can I react to
her yes please for
do we have any napkins I can do that I
could do the trick it's a magic trick it
goes with that I don't have napkins on
me I normally carry them but I don't
have it why can't I find his [ __ ]
reasonably maybe here you go mom
you're welcome his name is Jacob
Sartorius you're you're so perfect okay
let's hear it what are you what is your
reaction well first of all is he is he
over ten no she's 14 she's 14 he's 14
I'm trying to give you like a different
yeah
okay so first of all it was dire okay
he's a star clearly he's got enough yeah
what are your reactions to him on the
app that what do you think about that
well I think what's something obviously
just what you guys were saying before do
what you love right yeah so there's
something clearly very compelling about
him that he is loving that doing that oh
yeah he's just enjoying himself so much
that's so sweet
no that's actually a really nice thing
to say and also you know it is true so
say what you will about musically and
people who are musically but they are
having fun doing it they're making these
things it is fun you want to see what I
do to Jacob stories I'm watching a
compilation on YouTube no you're out
it's like I like how you just said that
that made me happy and honestly
musically we were like we didn't really
get it and then we tried it and it's
it's fun like we had a lot of fun on
musically yeah and we're both verified
so snap my way to Jacob so I just love
how everybody gets you know sort of
democratization in the internet you know
this is it people get to do what they
want it may know there's trolls and all
those bad things and that's you know
there's some cyber the pipe is I'm gonna
do that but so cool yeah I do things in
their dream innovate and change and have
fun and you know I love do you get why
people are a little bit like annoyed
that he literally lipstick other
people's music and that doesn't get paid
absolutely yeah
yeah so that part I get and you know
look ever since uh you know the
photographers are going through what the
music people went through which is if
people are just taking your images like
no that's brutal
I know
yes right kind of used to be it used to
be you know different just like it was
for musicians again think I'd pay
different although the Beast that ate
music there was a beast eating music
before and that was that were the
recording companies the record companies
right they ate the money blame us ate
the money from the musicians so the
artists quote-unquote traditionally gets
screwed anyway that's their finding just
a different balance yeah it's just a
different thing but you know the people
that came up in that business they made
money in photography and now they're
like we went to the LACMA yesterday and
saw pictures taken by robert
mapplethorpe and this was in the 70s but
like at least at a time when people knew
what a photograph by someone looks like
and appreciated their art form in the
idea there and now it's like you just
see a cool picture on the internet no I
didn't took it no idea no idea no you
don't care to screenshot it and post it
to your account what's stopping you yeah
right and it's very hard to find out so
I mean but then and then and then it
gets to the point of like from a
photographer's standpoint cuz I'm I
wouldn't teach myself a photographer but
I know photographers and I like then
becomes a question of do I water market
or is that scummy looking but then how
do I protect myself I don't I mean like
you have to kind of decide on how you
approach what you're doing it's still
there it's still appreciated and you
know so early do some photography with
that feeling when it goes viral and no
one credit to you like what happens with
videos comes with gifts yeah but the
thing about telling a story that's the
universal thing that's been going on for
centuries and the technology changes but
the ability to tell a story through a
picture or through a video or through a
song yeah and you know that's the
reinterpretation he's doing a
reinterpretation of it the poor for the
person who made the music unfortunately
isn't getting the you know the the
pennies for it or the sense or the money
or the dollars or whatever it is but you
know the reinterpretation that's that's
another way that art has changed because
up into a certain point you know you
could fake you could pick a fake fake
you could paint a fake Rembrandt and
maybe get money for that but there
wasn't any way to do mash up bream Brant
with Picasso and now come up with
something yeah
right and so now that's the thing you
know the whole mashup idea is you know
it's it's not entertainment in a lot of
very good ways and you know the TV world
hasn't caught up to it and they can't do
anything about it anyway but the
internet the way things are you know
mashups are what you know how how cool
things come about yeah so you know
digital photography and how photography
can be altered it's a very cool thing
it's just hard to you know you can't
make a living the way you used to yeah
you have to change with a question and
that's it's very interesting to hear you
talk about it I feel like I'm
enlightened right haha we should have
Jacob Centauri's on the vodka oh I think
it would I don't think why I thought he
liked you didn't he where does he live I
don't know he's a kid man he's like 14
yeah Jasmine Thompson was I know she was
young if she's a she's a singer hmm and
she well we play your music on Sirius
and I would tweet it I think about we'll
work on we're gonna I really want to
thank you for coming on the podcast
again I had a blast with you you're
wonderful thank you and such a pleasure
I love that you're in town don't wanna
do did you have a blast yeah so Julian's
coming tomorrow with the mom yeah mom
day tomorrow Mother's Day I don't have
been yesterday with you guys about
hopefully you called and called your
mother kissed your mother kiss someone
else is my mom what do you want to do
tomorrow my Mother's Day I want it just
to be with the children that is so nice
it'll be a nice feeling fun day yeah
guys make sure you go check out
headspace right now like it right when
you're finished watching this just go to
headspace calm slash Jenna Julianne
download the app and try it for free
guided meditation I want you to
experience what it's like to be guided
in meditating it very simple and easy to
understand format because it's really
awesome and then let me know your
thoughts on Twitter yeah because hear
from ya we are all so sorry I mean it
paid off we are also working on
something very cool for you guys to have
an outlet I don't want to say anymore
but
an outlet to live and breathe podcasts
more than just Mondays so we will keep
you posted on that I'm excited about
that but for now thank you so much heavy
machine for stopping my podcast we no
doubt have you guys on and another point
right we love you very much internet fan
loves you too yeah so it's cool merch in
the merch store you guys there's cool
merch in the merch store thank you for
reminding me all those cermets shirts
they're really dope and they have
podcast shirts and everything you want
because wallpapers is generally podcast
calm we appreciate you guys weekend and
I wish I could see you and hug you all
they have a lot of Twitter children you
know you have a lot of siblings hundreds
of thousands of them happy mothers sale
of the hundreds of thousands of you they
love you guys we will see you next week
for another podcast we appreciate you